you know what's the one thing that the
pandemic has done the pandemic has
exposed and tested many different
industries and organizations as well as
it's brought back up certain issues that
we talked about before but not as much
as we are talking about it
today so in this video I'm gonna share
with you 10 issues industries or
organizations that have been negatively
or just been impacted by coronavirus but
before I go into that I want to give you
some good news check this out
according to CNBC US savings rate hits
record 33% as coronaviruses causes
americans to stockpile cash and curb
spending look what Bank of America says
here at the bottom Bank of America says
somewhere here here we go Bank of
America which touches half of Americans
household said checking accounts have 30
to 40 percent more money in them
compared to 12 weeks ago CEO etc etc etc
okay so now let me give you another data
here total account when it comes out to
savings watch this you'll be blown away
by this this is the savings rate since
1960 America on average we were saving
10% then we went up to somewhere around
seventeen and a half percent in 1978
then it went down and down and down in
our Babis didn't get too good in about
30-40 years we were saving somewhere
around 5% hit a low of 25% in 2006-2007
and then looked boom 33% so now what
does this tell you it tells you we used
to be savers then we became spenders
because of a lot of TV marketing and hey
let's buy luxury luxury luxury luxury
luxury luxury and then BOOM oh my gosh
it's not really all about luxury maybe
just maybe cash is king
maybe we need more cash you know in the
bank when maybe we need more cash in
case a crisis takes place and people are
right now sitting there saying you know
what I hope they're thinking about the
same if I can save 33 percent during
these times let's just say I go back to
regular life what was i spending money
on that I don't need to spend money on
what was i buying that I don't need to
be buying what was i purchasing that I
can set aside for now and what if maybe
I can't be at 33% when I get back to
normal life well maybe I can figure out
a way to
15% marker because if you hit the 15%
marker of saving your salary you're on
your way to creating wealth now that's
not even one of the ten issues I wanted
to talk to you about it's just something
that came up that's good news that we're
saving money so let's get into some of
these industries first things first is
the airline industry the airline
industry employs ten point six million
people but you're also seeing the fact
that Airlines and TSA report ninety six
percent drop in air travel as pandemic
continues we've looked at the TSA
numbers to show that we used to get you
know 2.2 million flights a day you know
2.5 billion 2.6 million flights a day
this is last year same time of year ago
meaning 2019 and we went all the way
down I think April 17th or so what is
the date April right April 14th we were
averaging only 87,000 flights a day
travelers a day and today the travelers
went up Memorial Day and it kind of
picked up to 348 318 340 321 which means
we'll travel a little bit more that's
good news now let's look at the airline
industry why these guys got hit hard by
the pandemic most people don't realize
the airline industry's margins are only
three point two six percent I know it's
smaller you may not be able to see it
their cost and expense is ninety six
point seven four percent they barely
make any money let me speak to what this
means here's what this means
you know how companies who sell software
and you for instance do 20 million a
year but the twenty million year you do
70% is profits you're really doing what
40 million year versus another company
that does 200 million a year but their
profits there's only five percent
they're making only ten million a year
so so the company that's doing 20
million profits more than a company
doing 200 million because of what
they're profiting now what their
revenues are right
20 million revenue sixty seventy percent
profits twelve million 200 million
revenue five percent profits is ten
million
it's not about revenue it's about
profits and the airline industry's
profit net margin is three point two six
percent this is why you know the airline
industry's has historic historically
in the sexy industry let me go create my
own airline and most people don't
realize there's 27,000 commercial jet
aircrafts valued at 696 billion dollars
of which of which these Airlines
13300 commercial jets valued at 331
billion dollars are owned by operating
the lessers meaning they're being leased
they're not owned so these airlines like
Virgin Airlines you think it all must be
like a 20 billion dollar company it only
sold for 2.6 billion dollars 2.6 billion
dollars Alaska Air Group bought it for
two point that's a virgin you know
virgin the nice sexy airline that
Richard Branson starts and you know
you've been on it before the pink lights
and the music that they play it's not
that big of an industry and they got
exposed the airline industry is taking a
very big hit because people are starting
to realize you cannot go into an
industry just to be able to say hey I'm
gonna start my own airline that David
airlines why because it's such bragging
rights you can go do it it's a leasing
business it's not a big deal but it's
not as sexy as profitable as people
think it is people are starting to pay
attention to numbers they didn't pay
attention to before next time we're all
gonna look at here's the following watch
this Amazon again is Chappell izing in
the world I don't want to use but
similar to their exploiting this
opportunity they are looking at buying
AMC Theatres AMC stock just jumped up
just this last week May 27th why is an
Amazon merger now off the table is
Amazon wanting to buy Douai Amazon
gobbling up AMC Theaters doesn't make
any sense this is an article by observer
what do you mean it doesn't make any
sense let me explain to you guys let's
just say you're Jeff Bezos in your
Amazon who are you competing against
everybody Facebook Netflix Amazon Google
you're competing with all of these guys
why is there so much power form to pick
up at AMC who cares if he picks up a SC
it's on so it's only like what is it's a
company that I got started January 1st
I believe 1920 let's look at the recap
edia watch this January 1st
1920 let me go back to this
come on AMC Wikipedia where you at AMC
Wikipedia check the side okay AMC they
got started when come closer come closer
yeah generally first 1920 I was right
hundred years ago and have how many
theaters a thousand six theaters 11,000
screenings okay now watch this why would
Amazon be interested in buying a
thousand Peters here's why they would be
interested in mind a thousand theaters
you know what they get to do they get to
dictate and control a part of Hollywood
why we're not gonna play your movie
unless if you do this this is a form of
control I know I am seasoned at four
point nine billion dollars but if Amazon
owns them and they own prime they are
start to kind of figure out a way to
control a part of Hollywood and in a way
compete with Netflix because Netflix
doesn't have that so it's a very
interesting move these guys are making
nothing Amazon does is accidental the
whole book I'm writing your next five
moves that it's about me and methodical
these guys don't do stuff that's winging
it their be methodical so it's gonna be
interesting to see what the
entertainment industry's gonna do
especially with this purchase by Amazon
now let's look at the fitness industry
CNN business ninety four billion dollar
fitness industry is reinventing itself
as Koba 19 spreads what does this mean
24-hour fitness prepares for bankruptcy
while gyms start to open by the way this
is just from yesterday 24-hour fitness
filing bankruptcy Planet Fitness
competitor
Gold's Gym files bankruptcy so now
Gold's Gym is now filing bankruptcy LA
Fitness is kind of looking at it but
look what business has blown up peloton
could emerge much stronger after
coronavirus shut down and analysts say
chrono peloton who is peloton which one
of you guys has peloton yourself in your
house I know I do and I watched a
stockier peloton last six months peloton
was doing okay matter of fact they were
even going down a little bit all of a
sudden boom coronavirus comes they go up
why people are not buying peloton
this is something you can do from home
you can still do classes you can still
do spinning you don't need to have a gym
membership line I just go buy one for
three thousand dollars so the fitness in
this
three is about to go in a complete
different direction because especially
for those that innovate and pivot if
they don't they're gonna take a mess of
it the old model of gyms I just don't
see that thing I think they have to
definitely realize if they go the
waiters and say well you know things are
gonna go back to normal I wouldn't
invest I should work at Bally Total
Fitness and Bally Total Fitness
eventually follow bankruptcy you don't
want to be part of an industry that's
gonna do well for 8 9 12 15 years and
then one event every 15 20 years can
take these guys out if I'm going into
the gym business I'm changing it up and
um it's gonna be interesting to see how
they do now here's our next one watch
this hotel hotel industry here's some
scary stats the impact to travel
industry is 9 times worse than 9/11 look
at hotel occupancy rates 2011 58 percent
60 percent 61 62 64 this means 64% of
all the hotel rooms were being occupied
at 14 then 65 65 65 bone 38 percent
nearly 50% revenue decline in 20 2020
that's 124 billion dollars lost off to
270 billion total Oxford Economics 8 in
10 hotel rooms are empty right now 2020
is projected to be the worst in the
record of hotel occupancy worse your
ever think about that ever forecasted
occupancy rate for 2020 worse than 1933
Great Depression let me read that to you
one more time
forecasted occupancy rate for 2020 worse
than 19 1933 Great Depression and this
is leading to 70% hotel employees have
been laid off it's a scary thought
nearly one-point-six million hotel
employees out of work and 2.4 billion
dollars a week be lost wages this is
hotel what are they gonna be doing how
are they gonna be pivoted how are they
going to be making adjustments what's
gonna happen to some of these big hotels
that you and I are accustomed to going
whether it's the Marriott's of the world
or Hilton's of the world or some of
these other names the rinses the Four
Seasons what are they going to be doing
how are they going to be just and I'm in
the event I was about to do a big event
with MGM for seven million dollars
contracts everything signed and we're
going through this process and we're
gonna have to adjust we're looking at
things in a different way why because
that's a direction they're going so
Hotel
to sit there and figure right away I
think Vegas is getting ready to open up
this week I was talking to some of the
executives at MGM telling me where
they're at on what it's like it's ghost
town right now but Vegas has been shut
down because of this business the
entertainment business so it's gonna be
very very critical to see how they just
next Airbnb you've got Airbnb a
reference to your vacation rental
vacation real estate markets are toast
because of the pandemic as Airbnb owners
rushed to offload their homes
Airbnb owners rushed to offload their
home so Airbnb hosts are planning to
sell off their properties because the
pandemic that's the NN complete
different article Airbnb has reportedly
dropped its internal valuation to 26
billion dollars as a coronavirus halts
worldwide so the Airbnb model what are
they gonna be doing you know when you
buy rental properties I got a rental
property I got a vacation and I'm doing
this or people gonna go back to buying
those properties for the same reasons I
don't know how they're gonna be pivoting
now I'm not telling you this is
permanently going away I just don't know
how people gonna be pivoting here's
another topic that came up because of
coronavirus president Trump executive
order on preventing online censorship
this just happened by the way YouTube
here's Elon Musk just so just a few
weeks ago Elon Musk blasts YouTube for
banning California and doctors video
that claim physicians are being
pressurized into putting corona virus on
death certificates and urged urged an
end to its censorship we we talked about
censorship before but not this much
watch this one here with a debate who's
right Dorsey or Zuck when it comes down
to issues of politics you know Trump
says right-wing voices are being
censored the data says something else if
you haven't seen this article you got a
look at a conservative voices dominate
Facebook ben shapiro number one in its
Breitbart then it's liberal now this the
hill western journal then it's The Young
Turks then blaze IJ our Washington
Examiner CNN politics it's interesting
to see some of these things being talked
about now and look at the angles some
media companies are taking this is NBC
saying Twitter
places warning on Trump post saying two
tweets glorified violence and
and another one is Trump is at war with
the truth not Twitter coming from CNN
again they're taking shots I mean if
there's ever a title that's gonna piss
off Trump this is it right here
Trump is at war with the truth not
Twitter which led to Twitter saying
Twitter's not censoring Trump Trump and
censoring Twitter and then again it
keeps going on Trump's executive order
cracking down on online censorship has
nothing to do with free speech business
insider not defending Trump and this is
what Trump said about Twitter when he
was asked about it just yesterday or two
days ago
there's nothing I'd rather do than get
rid of my whole Twitter account but I'm
able to get to I guess 186 million
people when you add up all the different
accounts and and Facebook and Instagram
it's a lot of people and it's more than
the media companies have frankly buy a
lot and so when I get a story that's
wrong I can put any social media I don't
usually use the word footer I use I say
social media but I put something out and
the next day or the next hour the next
minute everybody's reading about it so
I'm able to if you think news and that's
very important so that's his battle
right there now watch what sucks is on
Fox just a day ago two days ago about
the role they playing censorship which
is slightly different than the world
Twitter is paying because Twitter is
saying no we can censor if you say the
following things facebook is saying to
follow look exact thing kits appropriate
for Facebook to do but we do have clear
policies and if anyone violates them you
know whether you're you know we I don't
think it's appropriate for Facebook to
do I don't think it's appropriate for
the family link below if you want to see
it he's talking about if you lead to
violence and you want there to be
violence obviously that's something that
we will take down but he said we're not
doing fat chicken so he's taking a
position to say we're just a platform
you got things that you need to say
we're not a media company we're just a
platform we're not going to do
fact-checking not everybody is happy
about this so this censorship has
created a very interesting topic on
sighs we're if we're leading to this and
and Trump is suing these companies or
maybe even going after them executive
order it's gonna be very interesting to
see how these companies respond during
times like this especially if he gets
reelected that's another issue here's
another one
Politico how coronavirus could make
people move not move as and let's move
let's go move our bodies and work out no
no physically move to a different place
leave New York leave Chicago leave
California all this data about people
leaving look at this I want you to watch
what these some of these folks are
saying you from New York and what some
people are saying from California
frustrated California's move out say
coronavirus pandemic was last straw
listen to this year but behind some of
the glass in this picture perfect scene
the corona virus has brought pain and
doubt to the American dream it's hard
suited to to keep up with a dose right
now Tim lamp an immigrant from Vietnam
his family arrived with next to nothing
30 years ago and now this restaurant
called bacon is what they have to show
for all of their work but with his doors
still closed profits have dropped 90%
the family is ready to move to Texas
which is opening up excellent already
affordable than California I blame the I
blame the states yes I do
he is not alone from state prep this
morning for a move to Florida you know
why I don't the trash the homeless
businesses which I believe could be
safely open one business in particular
it's close to home it's her husband's
film to digital transfer service when we
asked Mike Prichard about what role
Kovach 19 plays of their decision it's
challenging shall we say and that from a
man who wants to leave when I warned you
despite living 40 years in this state
can you look better somewhere else
quite possibly oh that's a reasonable
people you don't hear them like bashing
or anything they're just people that are
small business so these are not
millionaires billionaires they're just
guys like saying look I just can't do
this anymore so the other issue here
that's gonna be taking place I did a
video on it what was the title the video
ten reasons why you consider a move if
you've now watches you have to watch us
click over here I even have a PDF that
I'm texting you right afterwards if you
want to go through some of the date on
taxes stage policies you know real
estate taxes based on different states
people are right now talking about the
topic of moving more than ever before
because they're realizing how much
influence the local politicians have
over the effects of their businesses
meaning I'm running a small business a
politician can put your business out of
business
depending on what state you're living
and you better believe people are
thinking about that by the way this
article you know political it's not just
talking about the States it's talking
about Italy it's talking about Europe
it's talking about countries that are
sitting there saying I don't know what
I'm gonna be doing Milan Madrid Tokyo
all of these places this is not an
America thing people all over the world
are sitting there saying do I want to
build my family my business in the city
the state the country I'm living in and
it's something a lot of people are
talking about that's that's part of the
pandemic it's explosive here's another
one
Big Pharma the corona virus outbreak
suppose the u.s. pharma supply chain
which what does this really mean
Kovu 19 has exposed the limits of
pharmaceutical market model okay let's
can we go a little bit deeper than that
look look at some data right here as you
go down about one antibiotics okay and
yours you German someone's asked during
a fox and endogenous analog on foreign
forms of manufacture are 94% of
antibiotics of this country that's not
the data I want to show you there's one
right all the way in the bottom here you
go okay
the Japanese government has taken action
the government of Prime Minister Shinzo
Abe announced April 7 that it would
provide two billion dollars and
subsidies to help the Japanese companies
remove their supply chains back to Japan
from where obviously China on May 12 the
government knows that it has begun to
work with more than 400 domestic firms
to bolster production at home generic
drugs are among the most vulnerable
fields nearly half of Japan's API API
stands for active pharmaceutical
ingredient that's what API means not API
the other API active pharmaceutical
ingredients so again nearly half of
Japan's api's come from China and South
Korea in addition 70 to 80 percent of
masks come from where China and most
countries don't trust China anymore in
Europe French president Manuel macron
macarons macron said promised full
dependence by
a year in the production of protective
face masks for France I don't want to do
business with China in us the number at
the bottom if I can find it I remember
saying 13% CAI do you see the 13% number
70% 13% oh let me go here let me go here
72% FDA currently has no clear data to
track the amount of medicine imported by
the US instead it has only data on the
location the factors that produce those
drugs according to its data 72% of the
API which is the drugs manufacturers
supply the US market or located overseas
read the sentence again 72% of the API
API stands for active pharmaceutical
ingredients API manufacturers supplying
the US market are overseas 13% of those
manufacturers operate inside China so
this is this is quite scary because let
me get this straight
all these pharma companies and US are
sitting around saying we're building in
China and US you myself family my dad
gets medicine that he needs he's 78
years old he had a heart attack when he
was 50 something and he still around
what's going up it's because the right
medicine he's taking if China decides to
have a trade war issue with us and they
leverage their pharma this could get
pretty ugly very quickly for baby
boomers and elderly folks so the
pandemic exposed the fact that we cannot
have 73 percent of our api's coming from
you know markets outside of us that's a
scary thought to be 72 percent well
that's gonna be a big opportunity today
for pharmaceutical companies to say we
are made in USA if the word made in USA
has ever had more weight than today I
can't even tell you when we buy stuff
nobody looks at us made in China made in
China today it's more important to say
made in USA matter of fact if your
business owner entrepreneur running your
own company it'd be such a big selling
point for you to say 100 percent of our
products are made in the USA that's a
very important factor to consumers today
again expose due to the pandemic let's
keep going with another industry here
here's an x1 sports entertainment sudden
vanishing of
forge Duta coronavirus will cost at
least 12 billion dollars this is at
least 12 million dollars this was coming
May first now watch this so you know Rob
Manfred who is the commission of Major
League Baseball as if he wasn't already
the most hated Commissioner in sports
with what he did with Houston Astros and
yeah I don't think it's a big deal
what's the big deal about the trophy and
all this stuff you know many will call
him one of the worst commissioners of
all time in the history of sports let
alone baseball here's what they proposed
MLB offers players sliding paced skill
to return to play proposal and here's
what the numbers are if you were making
a four-year contract of 563 they're
proposing you go to 262 if you were
making 5 million year contract they want
you to go to 1.6 4 million if you were
making 20 million they want it to be
5.15 million if you were making 35
million they one should only take 7
point 8 4 million that this is a
proposal that baseball made now
logically it makes sense because
baseball is probably not going to get
the money but if they're getting the
money they have to pay for even Tom
Glavine was a pretty respected guy he
and another former baseball player here
said you know y'all turns on you ok here
we go here's what they say on twitch
every no I want to read them one with
Glavine this one with Glavine ok Glavine
and Chipper Jones - the best players
that they had on Atlanta Braves years
ago you know the 30 million people in
America that are out of work right now
they don't want to hear about
millionaire baseball players bitching
because they're only getting paid 25 or
30 percent of their salary this year
they don't want to hear that so I
thought Snell's comments could have been
worded a little differently I haven't
heard anything else
satis I can only imagine it's probably a
phone call away from Tony Clark and Rob
man for it so what's the point there are
people right now baseball that are
saying you know come back and play for
less and are people saying well women
why would I come back and play for less
you're making money why should I take
you so that's baseball they hit there
take in now this are many other sports
on the kind of hit they're taking
because of a pandemic games we've seen
these before this is the marathon
typically in Tokyo 300,000 runners would
show up in 2019 if you look at what that
looked like a year before this is 2019
by the way versus this year 2020 they
only have 200 runners versus 300,000
runners so industries are taking a hit
but not all of them some of them it has
to do with the leadership watch what
Dana White just did they know why have
249 right where Joe Rogan's sitting on
one side where all these guys are
sitting on Cormier sitting on a
different side and you're kind of
commentating the fight very weird but
249 UFC generates 700,000 paper views at
a price point of 64 99 I'll do the math
for you watch the numbers here UFC got a
little bit of criticism for it but watch
this 700 K buys pay-per-view times 64 99
is what forty five point four three
million dollars he paid his fighters a
high of five hundred thousand or low of
twelve thousand these are the fighters
what they got paid their salaries it's
roughly three and a half million dollars
all these fighters got paid three and a
half million dollars so three and a half
million dollars to pay fighters to make
forty five million dollars now you got
to rent the space those are men that's
what you call a massive profit margin
and I like how he's doing it look at
this here's Dana White just yesterday
test number fired accountability here's
what I'm doing I'm taking it serious I'm
not saying it to hoax but I'm still
running a business and running a
business boom see you've got to respect
the way Dana's leading the UFC
organization and that's one of the
reasons why you have she's got that kind
of a loyal followers right now without
anybody being in the audience still got
700,000 pay-per-view so MLB you know MBA
NFL some of you guys got to think about
what your game plan is gonna be now I
know and I've also got a massive you
know a 20-some billion dollar contract
with media and all these other things
that they sign but there are different
ways to improvise you're gonna have to
figure out a way to make your work at a
time like this so that's the
entertainment in the sports industry
let's look at the next one here I don't
know how many more I got left you but
let's look at commercial real estate
these guys gonna take a hit us
commercial real estate but braces for
defaults as pandemic cuts cash flows now
look it's not just the small companies
by the way Starbucks
asks for a break on rent for the next
year Starbuck Starbuck space roughly
what is it
on rent there was a number up here on
what they paid the company estimated it
lost 950 million dollars in sales first
quarter of fiscal second quarter due to
stores closures etc etc and they're not
going out there saying hey we want you
to kind of negotiate with us and we
don't feel oh here it is
the restaurant company one of the
largest in the country by number of
stores total landlords that starting
June 1st for at least the next 12 months
it will need to change lease terms and
base rent listen Starbucks is not asking
for 60 day or 30-day stay us in for 12
months now you've got to realize these
commercial Real Estate's if they don't
pay their own mortgages they're gonna go
out of business and they're gonna go
into default and Starbucks is a very big
customer by the way that's not the only
people landlords commercial tenants
negotiate rent breaks a mat coronavirus
disruption how struggling businesses can
renegotiate renters Harvard Business
Review so there's gonna be commercial
real estate is gonna take a hit and the
other part not a lot of people have
right now is companies are worried about
commercial real estate agents
specifically because their salespeople
commercial real estate agents are very
good at saying things like you know it's
funny coronaviruses actually shown the
value of office and this is why it's
booming right now commercial real estate
that's a sales person talking I relate
cuz I know what it is to sell but the
reality behind closed-doors philosophies
are changing people are deciding to work
from home you're seeing Google Facebook
a lot of these guys saying 50% of our
employees can work from home we don't
need that much commercial space Google
was about to buy a bigger project they
put a halt on it why they don't needed
those big campuses that they were
building they're not looking at it right
now so who takes a hit with that
possibly commercial real estate er to be
interesting to see how they pivot so
look these are 10 issues I had with you
that I'm talking to you about and I just
think it's very important for you to
look at for yourself because I run a
small business we have fewer than 500
employees we have 15,000 agents
nationwide we have 130 offices
nationwide nearly half a million square
feet of space and as a business owner we
immediately were affected by coronavirus
to see what we had to do what are some
of the leaks that we had were some of
the leaks that we
with issues of hiring firing training
you know technology we have to adjust
from a you know GoToWebinar WebEx to
another platform we have to figure out a
way to tailor all our presentations to
be effective on zoom' we have to get
compliance in place to understand what
it is to sell products on zoom' but we
ourselves were exposed and tested and we
let them say oh my gosh look what's
going on over here
but at the same time we had our biggest
profit a month last month in a month of
April and we have our biggest month
revenue eBay da top-line policies every
measurable category possible in the
history the company has been shattered
in the month of May because in these
industries if these companies if these
businesses they don't pivot quickly and
figure out a way to reposition
themselves to assume that's something
like this is gonna happen again in the
next 5 10 15 20 years because the next
time a coronavirus comes out say the
president is a Democrat you know what
they're gonna say if he doesn't shut
down they're gonna say hey well Trump
shut down and he did the responsible
thing and he shut down - two weeks
before there was no death there was only
one death when Trump shut down and he
closed China he did this and he did then
this presidents did it being very risky
that president is gonna be forced to
shut down and the pressure is gonna come
to them if it's a Republican president
they're gonna say Trump did it why
aren't you doing it there's gonna be so
much pressure which means this shutting
down game is not a something that's only
gonna happen one time I expect it to
happen a lot of times you know why
because even till today they say what we
don't know when we're gonna get a
vaccine we don't know when we're gonna
get a vaccine we don't know when we're
gonna get a vaccine uncertainty
uncertainty uncertainty so if business
models don't assume that this is going
to happen again in the next 10 20 30 40
years they are going to be affected in
the next 10 20 30 40 years so whatever
business you're looking at you got to
look at your business and say what can I
do to make it pandemic proof again if
you haven't yet watched a video where I
talk about 10 reasons to move to another
state click over here to watch this
video there's a PDF you definitely have
to look at to see the different taxes
sales state and real estate taxes on
different states if you haven't want to
click over here and if you're not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
you
[Music]